let's now take a little bit of a look at
what's going on with coronavirus we've
got four more days of data the corona
virus pandemic is kind of settling now
into trends that are more about policy
than early hotspots and it is becoming
very clear that it is overwhelmingly red
states where the case growth is
explosive now in the United States in
general red states have worse education
they have worse health care they have
lower incomes they have more poverty and
these are trends that we've seen in the
United States for a long time now
early on in coronavirus there were many
right-wingers who were almost delighting
from seeing hot spots in large
democratic cities often within
democratic states we are now more than
three months in we're starting to see
corona virus spread correlate more with
policy than simply where did it go first
and with some small exceptions this is
increasingly a red state problem take a
look at this map where you will see a
county-by-county growth level where
either the trends are going in the right
direction or in the wrong direction and
this is a much more precise way than
simply looking at states or the country
if your why I'll describe to you what
we're looking at but if you're watching
you will notice there are green and
yellow colored counties those are doing
well that means they are either fully or
almost under control with coronavirus
you then have orange and red counties
which are not good okay and as you can
see huge swaths of the country including
the Northeast most of the West Coast
other than California which continues to
be a problem much of the bluer states in
between are going in the right direction
and yet at a country level we have crazy
numbers of new coronavirus cases how can
this be well it's because of the really
disastrous red state counties almost all
of Arizona's going the wrong way large
parts of Texas Louisiana Alabama
Arkansas Oklahoma Georgia both Carolinas
Florida and if you look at day to day
case numbers the places that are now
regularly having the new single day case
records are still California we've
talked about
California but then it's places like
Florida Texas Arizona again the
Carolinas Georgia a couple of the early
hot spots New York and Illinois but then
Tennessee Virginia Ohio so do we have a
unifying theory about what is going on
here we we actually do and I'm going to
tell you what it is so that when these
right-wingers trot out the bogus talking
points you don't fall from them if fall
for them some of the talking points
we're hearing from the right are things
like this is a Democratic City problem
which spread no thanks to them into red
states it's the fault of the Democrats
we've heard red states have more cases
because they have more testing we've
heard this was allowed in from China
because of stupid liberal blue state
governors and now we all have a problem
thanks to them we've heard the numbers
are simply fake we've heard southern
states are a problem because Mexicans
are bringing the virus across the border
all of this is wrong all of this is
wrong
Trump brags that now no one is coming
over the us-mexico border Trump has said
the border is stronger than ever
other than States lying about how low
they claim cases to be the huge case
numbers are not because there is more
testing going on there really are more
cases this is all not true and here's
the unifying theory to understand early
on late 2019 early 2020 before we knew
what was going on before we understood
the disease and how it spread the
disease was seeded planted in urban
areas with high direct traffic to the
early hotspot so here in Boston we have
tons of flights to Europe and to China
and other parts of Asia non-stop flights
here to Shanghai Hong Kong Japan
multiple city you know Beijing etc so it
was seeded here in Boston New York has
two major airports that connect directly
to China in Europe JFK and Newark
Pennsylvania was an early hotspot
American Airlines has a huge hub in
Philadelphia huge flight hub back and
forth to Europe and even some flights to
Asia Chicago is a big hub for
American Airlines and United many
international airlines also have
nonstops to Chicago
you've got Los Angeles and San Francisco
airports so for two to three months
coronavirus was being seated before we
knew what was going on and that's why
those were the early hot spots when we
learned about what was going on and
started stay at home orders those places
already had a huge amount of disease
before we even had testing capacity it
was spreading for weeks and you had a
large base population which contributed
to huge spread in these places we had it
here in Boston New York Chicago etc so
early the spread was heavily related to
where are people flying in and out of
and giving it to other people now over
time some states adopted serious
policies for mitigation and some states
did not and over time the numbers became
less about flights and air travel which
have all but stopped but more about
policy and once you let the policy
differences play out for a few months
you see these dramatic reductions in
places that were early hotspots
Massachusetts New York Illinois
Pennsylvania which are crushing the
disease right now fortunately I'm really
thrilled by the way about what's going
on here in Massachusetts things slowly
reopening safely reopening which is good
to see and you see the explosion in the
places that didn't have strict
guidelines or they were simply ignored
that's what's going on in California by
the way California has strict guidelines
but from all of the people I know living
there a lot of people are just ignoring
them
that explains California it also
explains Arizona Florida Carolinas
Georgia Oklahoma Arkansas Alabama
Louisiana as the new growing hot spots
so policy clearly does matter and that
the rate things are going
if you don't reverse what's going on
right now in 15 days you are going to
have a large portion of the us-south
that is going to be the world hotspot
the there are states already Arizona's
growth rate for cases exceeds some of
the worst countries right now Arizona on
its own and meanwhile Donald Trump held
a rally in such a hot spot Oklahoma
whose case rate is going up dramatically
so that is the lay of the land right now
we'll have some more detail about this
tomorrow I am now on cameo you can book
me to troll your friends I got booked
for a bunch of Father's Day messages
this week Kamio dot-com slash David
Pakman or just search my name on the
cameo app tomorrow I'm gonna have a
really funny video I did for somebody on
cameo but we'll take a quick break and
be back after this